c'est un dossier sensible au
commissariat de tours on vous le disait
hier un policier de la BAC a été placé
en garde à vue le 9 mai dernier il
suspecté d'avoir consulté et détenu des
fichiers pédopornographiques sur son sur
son ordinateur personnel depuis l'homme
a été suspendu de ses fonctions est
placé sous contrôle judiciaire dans
l'attente de son jugement il devrait
être présenté devant le tribunal
correctionnel de Tours en juin après une
expertise psychiatrique explication et
précision de Clémence dausques un
sentiment de trahison à la fois
personnel mais aussi vis-à-vis des
institutions voilà les premières
réactions des collègues du policier mis
en cause le choc est tel qu'une cellule
d'écoute psychologique a été mise en
place pour les agents qui en auraient
besoin d'après les syndicats les
fonctionnaires proches du suspect ont
déjà été entendus dans le cadre de
l'enquête comment le quadrait génère
a-t-il été démasqué qui a donné l'alerte
selon la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique il s'agit de l'Office
central pour la répression des violences
aux personnes un qui disposent d'une
cyber patrouille qui peut se pencher sur
les dossiers de détention d'image P2
pornographiques de son côté la
préfecture affirme que l'effet se sont
uniquement limités à l'ordinateur
personnel du policier quels sont les
peines en cours si le délit est avéré
réponse avec Marc Morin avocat
consultant juridique le fait de
fractions pénale en l'occurrence un
délit qui est puni d'une peine maximum
de 3 ans de prison et de 45000 euros
d'amende là aussi il s'agit bien entendu
d'un maximum on constate que la
jurisprudence est parfois plus sévère
pour des policiers pour des hommes
politiques puisqu'on estime que de par
leur fonction ils doivent avoir être
totalement irréprochable et avoir une
certaine probité le gardien de la paix
faisait partie de la bague de Tours
depuis quelques années placée sous
contrôle judiciaire il a été suspendu de
ses fonctions le temps de l'enquête
c'est à dire qu'il a rendu ses affaires
ainsi que son arme de service il ne peut
en outre participer à aucune activité en
lien avec des personnes mineures un
conseil de discipline dont la date est
encore inconnue décidera de sa
suspension définitive ou non enfin
l'homme devrait comparaître à la fin du
mois de juin devant la justice un
rapport d'expertise psychiatrique a été
demandé